sie sehen in ganz deutschland
tatsächlich keine über sterblichkeit
über sterblichkeit heißt ja es muss aus
dem rahmen fallen wir haben im winter
eine sehr milde grippewelle gehabt das
heißt wir haben im winter sowieso
weniger todesfälle gehabt als sonst und
ich habe das so zu sagen wir auch sehr
sehr genau angeschaut
selbst mit den verstorbenen an corona
die wir gehabt haben kann man nicht von
einer über sterblichkeit sprechen das
ist glaube ich nur sehr sehr solide
aussage ich möchte aber und das sieht
herr gottschalk denke ich genauso es
gibt in vielen anderen ländern über
sterblichkeit an kroner corona ist
gefährlich wir haben es aber in
deutschland geschafft die epidemie so
klein zu halten dass wir keine über
sterblichkeit gesehen hatten weiterhin
natürlich masken tragen wir müssen vor
allen dingen in den räumen aufpassen wir
halten uns mehr in den räumen auf die
kanzlerin hat schon gesagt man sagt
schon mal ein kanzler man muss sozusagen
das lüften ernst nehmen das ist aber
tatsächlich so glaube ich dass eine gute
möglichkeit und wir müssen weiterhin mit
dem mund nasenschutz in vielen
situationen leben und bitte lassen sie
sich alle grippe impfen auch das ist
sinnvoll
vielen dank professor salzberger für
diese einschätzung am morgen
dankeschön mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bosch audi das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren